-The president
is still resisting calls
to release his tax returns
while complaining
about immigration laws.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
President Trump
has been resisting calls
for over three years
to release his tax returns.
Last week Trump said he would
love to release them but can't
because of a fake audit
that definitely does not exist.
And he just kept repeating
the same words over and over.
-While I'm under audit,
I won't do it.
If I'm not under audit,
I would do it.
I had no problem with it.
But while I'm under audit,
I would not give my taxes.
There's no law whatsoever.
Now, I will say this.
I would love to give them,
but I'm not going to do it
while I'm under audit.
It's very simple.
-Every time Trump
answers a question,
he sounds like a scientist
insisting on giving a TED Talk
despite a recent
massive head wound.
"A black hole
is a hole that's black,
and it's black because it's
a hole where there's no light,
because it's black
and it's a hole.
And that's why they call it
a black hole."
"Dr. Trump, maybe we could
finish this up tomorrow?"
"But I haven't even gotten
to the black hole part yet."
Also, this part right here
is the best part.
-Now, I will say this.
I would love to give them,
but I'm not going to do it.
[ Laughter ]
-He tees it up like
he's about to switch gears
and then just
repeats himself again.
It's like if you ask someone
to marry you
and they said,
"Well, it's awfully soon
and I'm a little afraid
of commitment,
but I will say this.
No."
[ Laughter ]
Knowing that the audit excuse
is a transparent lie,
Trump has, in the last few
months, moved on to a new excuse
that his tax returns
are too complicated
for people to understand.
That's what he said last year
after Democrats won the midterms
and gained the power
to request them.
-As I've told you,
they're under audit.
They have been for a long time.
They're extremely complex.
People wouldn't understand them.
They're done
by among the biggest
and best law firms
in the country.
Same thing with
the accounting firms.
The accountants are a very,
very large, powerful firm
from the standpoint of respect.
A highly respected, big firm.
A great law firm.
You know it very well.
They do these things.
They put them in.
But people don't understand
tax returns,
and it is a very big company,
far bigger than you
would even understand.
But it's a great company.
But it's big and it's complex
and it's probably feet high.
-All right, first of all...
I don't want to hear
how big and complex it is
from someone who also says
it's feet high.
Second, the only thing harder to
understand than your tax returns
is that answer.
We need an audit just to figure
out what the hell you're saying.
Like, honestly, please,
what does this mean?
-A very, very large,
powerful firm
from the standpoint of respect.
-Why --
Why does the president
of the United States
always sound like a spam e-mail
asking you for your
Social Security number?
"Hello. I am with a very large,
powerful firm
from the standpoint of respect.
Will you please send
your bank routing number?"
For real?
For real, maybe Congress
would have more luck
getting his tax returns
if they just used his syntax
in the request.
"Mr. President, some would say
best president,
we're writing to request
your tax returns.
Are willing to send truck
to pick up, as they are so big,
massive even, from your many
large and successful businesses.
Wow!
We realize they will be
very, very too complicated
for us to understand,
as we are small from
the standpoint of intelligence,
but would be fun to see them."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
"They make a very good case.
I think we should
send them over."
Now, the law is clear.
Democrats have the power
to request Trump's tax returns,
which they did, and the request
went to the IRS, not Trump.
It's not up to him.
And yet on Sunday, his
press secretary, Sarah Sanders,
insisted Trump
would not turn them over,
and she even took Trump's
argument one step further,
saying members of Congress
were literally too dumb
to understand them.
-This is all about
political partisanship.
-This is a dangerous,
dangerous road.
And, frankly, Chris,
I don't think Congress,
particularly not this group
of congressmen and -women,
are smart enough to look through
the thousands of pages
that I would assume that
President Trump's taxes will be.
-Okay, now,
this is what she wants.
She's trolling us.
She wants us to get all mad
and riled up
and point out all the ways that
Trump is actually the idiot,
because that's
their only move --
to just take whatever
we say about Trump
and turn it back on us,
and we're just too dignified
for that.
We will not stoop to her level.
And I'm just kidding.
Here's a bunch of dumb [bleep]
the president's said and done.
-Our hope is a word and world.
Through their lives
and though their lives.
They sacrifice every day
for the furniture --
future of their children.
10,000 known or "suspested"
gang members.
Nancy Pelosi, or Nancy,
as I call her.
-What is that?
What -- What is --
Wait a second.
Is that toilet paper?
-It's tremendously big
and tremendously wet.
We appreciated very much
Tim Apple.
China has total respect
for Donald Trump
and for Donald Trump's very,
very large a-brain.
-"Very, very...
Very, very large a-brain."
Yeah, no, but we're too stupid
to understand the tax returns
of someone who's
clearly suffering
from what's known
in the medical community
as degenerative
Italian stereotype disease.
He'll start his next
press conference by saying,
"I use-a my very large-a brain-a
to make-a the pizza pie."
Now, I will concede
if Sanders is talking about the
Republican members of Congress,
then, yes, some of them
are not smart enough
to understand
Trump's tax returns,
like the guy who vaped
during a congressional hearing
or the guy who brought out
a giant meme of Ronald Reagan
riding a velociraptor
and holding a machine gun
or the guy who brought
a snowball onto the Senate floor
to claim that global warming
isn't real.
But if you compare that
to the Democrats,
specifically the new class
of freshmen Democratic women
who took office this year,
it's different,
like California congresswoman
Katie Porter,
a law professor
and consumer advocate.
Earlier this year,
she grilled Trump's pick
to lead the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau,
Kathy Kraninger,
who has no experience
in consumer protection.
Porter specifically asked her
to explain the difference
between an interest rate
and an APR.
Now, I don't know
the difference.
I looked it up three times
this morning,
and I still don't remember.
And I can guarantee you
this guy doesn't understand it,
but the director of the bureau
that's in charge of protecting
consumers from predatory lenders
should absolutely understand it,
and yet when Porter
asked Kraninger
to explain the difference,
Porter had to explain it to her.
-Could you please explain
to this committee
the difference between
an interest rate and an APR?
-So, the APR
is the extrapolation
if it were a one-year term.
-Ms. Kraninger,
the annual percentage rate --
and I'll be happy
to send you a copy
of the textbook that I wrote --
explains that the APR is derived
from the finance charge,
the amount financed,
and the payment schedule.
-Damn, she literally pulled out
the textbook she wrote.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is --
That is every academic's dream.
"You don't know nothing
about monarch butterflies!"
"What? Oh, my God.
Are -- Are you [bleep] serious?
I wrote the book
on monarch butterflies."
While Trump is resisting calls
to release his tax returns,
he's also been suggesting
breaking the law
when it comes to immigration.
Now, here's what's going on.
It's very simple.
Trump hates the fact
that migrants
can legally come to this country
and seek asylum.
He's been whining about it
for months,
complaining that migrants
have the right
to make their case to a judge
in a court of law
with the help of a lawyer.
And he did it on Friday
and yet again today.
-We have to do something
about asylum.
And to be honest with you,
have to get rid of judges.
They have to get rid
of the whole asylum system
because it doesn't work.
And, frankly,
we should get rid of judges.
We have a stupid system
of courts.
It's the craziest thing
in the world.
We then have to ask them
a couple of questions.
Lawyers are telling them
what to say.
They read a little page
given by lawyers
that are all over the place.
You know, lawyers.
They tell them what to say.
People come in.
They read a line from a lawyer
that a lawyer hands them out
online.
The asylum laws
are absolutely insane.
They're given a statement
to read
by lawyers that stand there
waiting for them.
Read the statement.
-I think Trump is just upset
that they can read
prepared statements,
because he can't read
prepared statements.
Whenever he reads off
a teleprompter, he Magoos it.
So he can't get rid of courts
or judges or lawyers.
So now Trump has moved on
to a new idea,
and he clearly thinks
this new idea
is a brilliant
political maneuver
that will turn the tables
on Democrats.
Trump said on Friday he wants
to start sending migrants
to liberal cities
that would welcome them,
or so-called sanctuary cites.
-We are looking at
the possibility --
strongly looking at it,
to be honest with you.
California,
the governor wants to have
a lot of people coming in,
refugees coming in,
a lot of sanctuary cities,
so we'll give them
to the sanctuary cities
maybe to take care of.
We'll bring them
to sanctuary city areas
and let that particular area
take care of it,
and let's see if they're
so happy.
They always say,
"We have open arms."
They're always saying
they have open arms.
Let's see if they
have open arms.
-Man, Trump's press conferences
are so crazy,
now the people
standing behind him
have to wear helmets
and harnesses.
[ Laughter ]
"You'll be standing
behind the president."
[ Laughter ]
So that's your brilliant
chess moves --
to send poor migrant families
fleeing poverty and violence
to cities that actually
want to welcome them.
This is one of the
dumbest attempted trolls
I've ever heard.
We've all --
We're actively volunteering
to take in more refugees,
and Trump is like, "Oh, I know.
I'll let them take in
more refugees.
That will show them."
It's like if a friend
volunteered
to pick you up from the airport
and you were like, "Oh, yeah?
Well, if you're so good
at picking people up
at the airport,
then why don't you come
pick me up at the airport?"
And you'd be like, "Okay,
I'll see you at the airport."
Whether it's on immigration
or tax returns,
there's one consistent theme
in Trump's behavior.
He just doesn't think
the law applies to him.
The Constitution grants people,
including immigrants,
certain inalienable rights.
And it also gives Congress
the power
to investigate the president.
But Trump can't seem
to get that through his...
-...a-brain.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]